now I'd like to welcome today's
presenters Tom Byers is a professor in
the department of management science and
engineering here at Stanford University
is a holder of the entrepreneurship
professorship endowed chair in the
School of Engineering and is also a bass
university fellow in undergraduate
education he has been a member of
advisory boards at Harvard Business
School UC Berkeley World Economic Forum
and Conservation International Tom was
executive vice president and general
manager of Symantec Corporation during
his formation and started his career at
Accenture our second presenter is Jack
Fuchs
Jeff Fuchs is a co-founder of Blackhorn
ventures and an operating partner Jack
focuses on sourcing new investment
opportunities and providing in-depth
mentorship to founders he's also a
Stanford lecturer on entrepreneurialism
providing valuable insights to both
founders and Blackburn partners based on
his depth of network and experience
previous in his career jack held several
senior positions with becton dickinson
and company including vice president of
worldwide marketing and was an
engagement manager with McKinsey and
company so that's it I like to turn it
over to you Tom and Jack thank you Joe
good morning jack and good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever you are
on this planet were really humbled to
hear about the number of people that
signed up for this webinar super excited
to talk to you for about a half an hour
and then leave lots of time for Q&A so I
have the honor of talking about our
motivation for even wanting to do this
webinar but also for spending a
considerable amount of time thinking
about the ethics of innovation and
entrepreneurship over the last couple of
years we are and we feel like we're just
getting started so let's talk about the
news and you don't have to look very far
to be reminded how important
ethics and values and principles the
subject of today's webinar are in
general I mean I've been looking forward
to this morning for a while I've had 12
12 19 circled on my calendar and I was
thinking when I got up this morning what
would I see when I opened the Wall
Street Journal I know you can tease me
but I still get the print edition in
addition to the online okay you know
exactly and what did I see button that
above the fold wasn't that we worked
this time oroboro ther knows but it was
about the FAA new Boeing 737 max was
risky but they allowed flight so classic
engineering ethics situation so
technology is it the only one that faces
these it's just that it's had is
specifically digital technologies it
just had a bit of a free ride up until
recently the last two or three years are
deeply concerning to everyone including
us who teach entrepreneurship and we
teach entrepreneurship here at Stanford
out of the engineering school as you've
heard we have colleagues in the business
school and elsewhere the medical school
but we specifically think about
entrepreneurship and innovation as
applied to science and technology so a
core for disturbed when we see stuff
like classic engineering ethics issues
regarding product safety but when it
comes to digital technologies there's
and I guess this was a software problem
to begin with so frankly it is really
directly related I don't know if I have
to go on very maybe that's why you did
this webinar folks that's my man you
turned in is you feel the same way so
I'm gonna assume that it's a crisis and
a crisis as we like to say around here
is a terrible thing to waste I mean
that's a we think like entrepreneurs
even though we're just we're teaching it
now and it it motivates us to go and
start thinking about what can we do
differently so there's a pretty busy
slide in front of you I'll get to in
just a moment but let me give one more
preface here entrepreneurship education
and and and I'll include innovation
education
that has exploded in the last 20 years
just like tech has become so much a part
of all of our lives in the last 10
especially but entrepreneurship
education and on University campuses and
colleges campuses every not just the
Stanford's and our peers but the entire
range of colleges and universities as
truly taking taken off I mean just to
get caught you when I got here in the
late 90s there were maybe Oh at most 10
and that's being generous courses on
innovation entrepreneurship available
for both undergraduate and graduate
students now they're counting depending
on who you won't want to believe
somewhere between 100 and 150 in other
words 10 times more courses that means
10 times more faculty teaching the
subject and we're just two of them the
two Jack and me so it's pretty
remarkable and until every I'll speak
for myself I always thought I was
stressing that people you know think
ethically and so on but in my textbook
which is in its fifth edition and I
promise you this is not a replacement
this textbook called Technology Ventures
from idea to enterprises 20 and 20 years
worth of additions ship the fifth
edition two years ago and Jack's heard
me talk about this before there's 20
chapters and guess what the last section
is in the last chapter that's the
section that says ethics and and this
was just as little as two years ago we
just finished this side this fifth
edition so you know shame on us but that
was when this beginning of this
awakening happened at least for me and I
noticed frankly across the entire
discipline of entrepreneurship educators
so what so what does this mean for you
though and this is why I want to
transition to Jack we've got lots of
frameworks and models to teach this
subject and both convey knowledge as
well as skill develop skills and our
students lots of them and in some of the
bin' action
even gotten into a common you know
common language like pivoting and and
things like that so it's lots of
frameworks and models but really not
enough attention given to ethics and
this is why we at the Stanford
Technology Ventures program which is the
Entrepreneurship Center here at the
engineering school Jack and I are part
of that and we opened up a project that
we call peak principled entrepreneurial
action and knowledge principled
entrepreneurial action and ology and
it's really just a codename it's just a
way to describe our current efforts to
do what you see on this slide here equip
a new generation to brave entrepot
dilemmas as well as create and adapt
innovative curriculum and on the
right-hand side I understand of your
screen is a website called peak dot
stanford.edu or a website for peak dot
stanford.edu and if you click to that
you can see the the breadth of
activities that we are we've kicked off
here and you see our collaborators at
Duke University as well as the
University of st. Thomas and Minneapolis
and you see a number of things and you
can take a look at that anytime they
also has about twelve short-form videos
of entrepreneurs and venture capitalists
and others that care deeply about this
as well embedded in the site at various
places so I call your attention to that
that that's our motivation that's how
were organized and now I'd like to turn
it over to my good friend Jack who has
taught has created a course about this
and I'm just so impressed by that I
wanted to expose it here on the webinar
Jack thank you Tom and so so under the
peek umbrella we have developed a course
we talked for the first time last winter
at Stanford we're teaching it again this
winter we also teach global workshops to
companies and organizations around the
world where we help folks develop their
own sense of what their values and
principles are we for the course and for
the workshops we've written case
vignettes about entrepreneurs
predominantly who are
met with difficult situations and where
those situations would be best solved by
being in touch with their values and
their principles and these situations
can be if you're running a company these
situations can be if you're running a
project team if you're involved in a in
a in part of any kind of organization
you can imagine that there are values
and principles associated with that with
that organization and so we have guest
speakers and we've had the CEOs of
leading companies such as CloudFlare
jazz pharmaceuticals Bloom Energy
tableau and Bridgewater who come to the
class and the students engage in a
discussion about this difficult
situation that was facing that company
in front of the protagonist and then the
protagonist comes up afterwards reacts
to what the students have said shares
what decision they made in that
situation and most important shares why
they made that decision here were my
principles and values associated with
what was going on or here's what our
team was wrestling with that led us to
make the decision that we did and the
important thing about these cases that
we do is that there is not one right
answer for any of these cases the ideal
situation is where the answer depends on
what a particular person or a particular
company's values and principles are and
so as we go through this journey we
expose those entrepreneurs to the
decisions that I've described
we have frameworks and guest speakers
who are responding to those and the goal
is that we have then helped the
entrepreneurs develop their own values
and principles that they can take with
them as they're leading an organization
in the course we focus on two important
concepts we use the term values and
principles very often we use the term
values to mean fundamental beliefs that
allow us to make general
judgments about what is good or what is
bad those tend to be less evolutionary
they tend to be something that's a
little more static
yes values do a lot do evolve but
predominantly values are with us and
those values Drive principles principles
are actionable rules of conduct for
making both life and business decisions
principles are derived from our values
and they help us navigate through to be
able to achieve our company or our
team's mission and when we when we talk
about values and principles there are
three different distinct levels of
analysis that we have when we when we
work with values and principles we as we
as individual people derives from our
ethical frameworks derived from society
but derived from all of our upbringing
and all of our experiences we have
developed a set of values and principles
ourselves about how we conduct our lives
organizations have their own set of
shared values and principles those
shared values and principles if we are
running a company if we're fortunate
enough to be a founder or a leader of a
small company we have broad ability to
influence the values and principles of
that company if we are part of a large
organization we still have the ability
to influence the values and principles
of that organization at least in our
little corner of the organization but
also more broadly within the
organization but how we live our lives
yes sir
well and I just want to say in your
class last winter which was made up of
both undergraduate students here in all
sorts of majors right humanities
sciences engineering as well as graduate
students primarily I believe from the
sciences and technologies but in that
class of 60 some of our students they
really appreciated that you included
individual and but they because a lot of
times in these ethics courses they're
either a skewed way to the left and then
a bit
or they're talking about boardroom
dynamics which they don't can relate to
but they they appreciate you found a
sweet spot and I think organization was
the sweet spot and the and the and the
the students did a the students in the
class particularly did a great job over
the course of the term as they as they
listen to each case as they debated them
as they heard from the entrepreneurs
that were in front of the class about
what they decided and how they how they
live their lives the students develop of
their own frameworks and their own
approach to to entrepreneurship and as
the discussions progressed throughout
the term they were more and more often
using their own principles as the basis
for how they were to Scott discussing
what decision they would make within a
particular case in within a privileged
situation the third level of analysis is
community even a company or a group of
people has their own shared values and
their principles but so too does an
industry or does a geography the medical
device industry as a particular set of
values and principles distinct and
different from social media gaming for
example for example or a certain region
of the United States can have a
different set of community values and
principles from from those in another
region and very very clearly Brazil or
China or Central Europe or wherever
wherever you are and whatever community
you're in there is a distinct set of
values and principles what will be the
values and principles of artificial
intelligence and machine learning that
is the big meta question nowadays
correct well and and and actually some
of those some of those things that span
that's that span countries right yeah in
that in that case that spans countries
and I just read about how we might not
even have one internet right of the
future we could wind up with multiple
Internet's and so we may have one set of
values and principles associated with
the Chinese internet and another
potentially with Europe and India and
another with the United States all based
on different fundamental principles for
example
openness right or of or of what is free
speech me so these are these are things
that we wrestle with in the class and in
a few slides I'm going to share with you
one very specific example of a case that
we use in the class but the whole idea
for this class and for workshops that we
conduct is so that these students
develop a of their own framework where
they have a sense of what their own
individual values and principles are
what an organization if they were going
to start a company or an organization
that they're currently working with and
I and I encourage you we're gonna be
asking you about this in a few minutes
think about one of your organization's
that you're in it could be a project
team that you're on it could be a
company that you're running it could be
a leadership team of some kind that
you're part of whatever some were a
church group whatever organization you
have think about the values and
principles associated with that group
just for just put that put that on the
back burner for a second and I mentioned
the word congruence here one of the most
important things when I look back on my
career the times when I've been the most
energized and at the most at peace with
what I'm doing in my career is when my
individual values and principles are
congruent with those of the organization
that I'm working with now they're never
going to be exactly the same even if
you're the one running a company you
don't have the exact same values and
principles for the company as you do for
your life but there are some times when
those principles and values are
congruent and there's some times when
they are in conflict and I think that's
what leads to some discomfort so we we
have not only worked to develop this
course that that Tom and I have been
talking about but we have worked to
inject principles into the curriculum of
other other folks throughout Stanford of
helping provide more guidance and help
to ensure that as broad a set of courses
as possible at Stanford incorporate
values and principles and ethical
education in
in their curriculum I'm not going to go
into a lot of detail on this on this
slide but we offer we offer people the
opportunity to use some of our case
study protagonists we are we are very
much trying to help people appreciate
that using terms like values and
principles can sometimes help allow
students to find more of their own true
north instead of trying to use words
like ethics which tend to imply a right
or wrong you're either ethical or
unethical as opposed to allowing
students to find their own sense of what
are the what the values and principles
are we want to make sure that the
educators themselves go beyond just
trying to figure out how to deal with
ethical crises like as Tom talked about
the Boeing situation or Volkswagen or
Wells Fargo or certainly Facebook and
uber and all those folks but we go
beyond those and inject principles into
the standard processes throughout their
their lives and throughout their
organizations and then what we try to do
in our course and what we encourage
other people to do is to model
respectful but contentious debate and
what we what we believe is that just as
in in companies also in courses but
think about in companies if instead of
arguing about whether you should treat a
customer this way or this way and you
argue about a specific situation if
instead you have a principled based
argument a principled based argument
about what is what principles of our
company are at play here and you have a
discussion among your leadership team
about those principles by having that
level of discussion it can much more
easily influence the kind of decision
that you make as a company it doesn't
it's not a recipe that gives you an
exact answer it just gives you a better
chance of making a better decision when
when times are tough time did you want I
sure thought about that well we stand on
the shoulders of people who had laid the
groundwork for this
we're just we're applying we are we are
we are awakened because technology is
having such impact and we've recognized
that it's not covered enough in our
discipline of innovation
entrepreneurship education but the
people like professor frame in the
university of virginia who invented
corporate social responsibility and
stakeholders theory so we we haven't due
respect to all of that in what we're
trying to do is extend it into well
startups don't really think about
corporate social responsibility and and
so that's that's where we're coming from
but due respect to what people have done
before so what about some cases it is a
spin off of that when you think about
studying and understanding ethics and
values and principles we believe that
there's a top-down and a bottom-up
approach right that there are these
frameworks and and and the the
tremendous work that's been done to help
students appreciate and understand and
develop their own values and ethics and
then that there's also a role for for
specific case examples for situations
where where you can use either either a
case like stuff that's happening with
Facebook or cases that we do for the
class or helping students understand
more specifically the things that will
happen to them as they're exposed to to
the world of business or whatever other
pursuits they decide to choose to use
those specifics to help the students
generate their own frameworks but
whether the startup is independent or
whether it's part of a larger enterprise
in business and education and government
if startups have particular ethical
dilemmas presented to them you know and
that is what makes what we see is a big
gap in terms of curricula and frankly
just opportunities for this current
generation of students to learn from
sure and and so as we as we move forward
and as we move to some specific examples
that you might have in project teams or
in companies that you work in and as we
go through the cases I just want to help
people appreciate we believe that
principals should be a
broad as possible you might you might
you might believe as I do that one of
the reasons that Facebook had so many
missteps in their dealing with some of
the in the data and information
situations that have presented
themselves to Facebook over the past
couple of years is that their set of
principles they have principles but
those principles perhaps are too narrow
it may be that the leadership of
Facebook was was the kind of leadership
that wanted things to be clearly black
and white and so they had a set of
principles that all were mutually
exclusive and collectively exhaustive
and didn't conflict with each other
we believe that principles are
inevitably going to conflict with each
other and that you should as a person
and you should as an organization have a
broad set of principles that helped
inform your decisions and that within
the context of a particular decision you
then prioritize those principles in that
situation to help you to help make the
decision that you want to make at
Facebook perhaps if the decision if the
principle was all about engagement and
optimizing for engagement and there
weren't other counterbalancing
principles to have a principle based
argument if people will always make the
decision based on trying to maximize
engagement at some point they are going
to run afoul of some other values and
some other community community based
values and ethics and so so we encourage
students to have develop a broad set of
principles and I just put up this on
this slide we think of these principles
in a cat one category of organizational
principles principles that inform
relationships within your country within
your company I'm sorry the processes
that you have as a company the culture
of your company the leadership of your
company how you hire people how you
recruit people then there are
operational principles that determine
how you run your sales and marketing and
then product and all of those
fundamental air
is an operation for your company and
then stakeholder relations the way the
company relates to its investors board
members partners people outside the
company and so again I'd like you to
think about principles I'm not going to
to go in yet to specifics but I now want
you to think about organizational
principles operational principles and
stakeholder type principles within a
within an organization that you're
currently working in of some kind again
it can just be a project team if you
want or a company or any other
organization and our first poll question
is I'd like you to consider a difficult
decision or a problem facing that
organization that you're a part of and
I'd like you to consider what principles
are at play that could help your
organization resolve the problem that
you're currently working on so think
about that problem and think about what
principles are inherent or embedded in
your organization that would help you if
you were gonna have an argument about
where to go with that and then answer
one of those four things are they a
broad set of principles that are widely
understood have been agreed to in
advance by that organization are they
understood implicitly but they're not
explicitly stated are they an incomplete
set of principles that could possibly
skew the decision where there may be
some principles that are really
well-known and others that aren't as
clear or are they not generally
understood principles some pick one pick
one and vote on it and then we kind of
start to see how how things have all ago
and and I think that you you should you
should reflect on now a couple of things
for those that are that voted toward the
bottom where the where the principles
are not generally understood think about
how the discussion about that problem
could have been different if before it
started to rain before these problems
existed you
had set up a common set of principles he
would discuss them you had agreed on
some on some ways that you were gonna
treat customers or ways that you were
gonna treat your employees or ways that
you were gonna partner with other
organizations around your company if you
had if you had understood those if you
had if you would discuss them if you had
agreed on a set of guiding principles in
advance how the conversation and maybe
even the decision would have been
different with what you're wrestling
with now maybe another one is ways
you're going to communicate about your
progress I mean this is this
entrepreneurs reality to distortion
field you know yeah yeah theory or myth
that by being too optimistic thinking
you can actually come across as you know
putting deception is more important than
reality well and that's you know one of
the things that I was struck I was I was
meeting with an entrepreneur last week
and he had written one of the cases for
our our course and he and he just
started a company and he said I am
struck with how often principles are at
play right from the start of the very
first day that we start the company
we're trying to we're trying to
negotiate with the with with it's not
Stanford University but with the
university about the technology utilized
to get the license and how much do you
share with that University about what
your aspirations are because they might
be talking to other licensees right
you're now going to a customer and the
product isn't quite ready how do you how
do you where do you draw the line what
do you tell the customer is completely
working versus will work by next Tuesday
versus we're hoping is going to work and
these are all things your principles if
you have principles as a company that
are understood you at least create those
lines more clearly and that way more
people throughout your organization are
going to abide by those and for the
folks that are that
answered up toward the top of the list
where their principles are really well
understood I'd like you to think about
not only did that help you as an
organization make a better decision or
at least make a decision in a better way
but did it also affect how you
implemented that decision because
principles not only affect what you do
and what you decide to do but those
principles also affect how you do it
whatever decision you make how do you
how do you let that roll out and just
surprise you so you know I think these
percentages one of the one of the things
that we don't know right is how many
people are thinking about an individual
small organization and how many are
people are thinking about a large
company I do think that I do think that
by and large people are people tend to
think that the principles are more
broadly understood than they actually
are now I don't want to disagree with
the poll we asked you to map the vote
and you vote in a stood for the top
right which is which is fine but I think
that's that's as much a function I think
it's true that people are more in touch
with principles and values than they
were but I also think that people tend
to think that they are more broadly
understood leaders at companies tend to
think that the people throughout the
throughout the their organization are
more interests and thank you for
updating this is that's that's wonderful
so please don't let me influence your
whole which is this actually makes me
feel even more energized for us to work
for at least once college students when
their their minds are open we have a
chance to and and they're eager to learn
innovation entrepreneurship we have a
real opportunity okay so let's do it
okay so as I as I so yeah I'll do a case
and then I'll come back to those points
yeah so one of the one of the cases that
so the usually the first case that we do
in our in our course and the students
the goal is for the students to to
interact and
Bay and discuss the case in a way where
they're not intimidated by the fact that
the CEO is in the room and for this
first case the students don't even know
that the CEO is in the room but then
certainly by the second or third week
Stanford student so they start looking
in the back yester the pattern
recognition kicks in and they're aware
that the CEO is in the room so we want
to make sure that the students are not
intimidated at all by that and that
they're willing to disagree with the CEO
they're willing to or disagree with what
the CEO did and and this is a classic
situation that people have probably
people if you're familiar with things
like the Volkswagen you know stuff and
and General Motors had a situation where
they they were aware of things happening
with the ignition in their cars and
people were dying in this situation a
company that sells a product that
inflates truck tires to their optimal
pressure they developed a really cool
product that bolts onto the outside of a
truck wheel and you attach the nozzles
to the you touch the the hoses to the
nozzles of the tires and it uses the
trucks the wheels rotational motion to
generate enough pressure to to keep the
tires inflated to their optimal pressure
reducing tire we're reducing blowouts
which are really dangerous and improving
fuel economy it's a really neat product
it's a neat company it came out of our
course at Stanford they the the the
founding team took the MS&E 273 course
one of the one of the courses we've been
teaching at Stanford fro for quite a
while and and they they are they develop
a wonderful industry reputation they
wind up with 50,000 trucks on the road
with these with these inflation devices
on them companies about five years old
or so and they know and and what they
have done because of the kind of company
they are and I won't go through but
there are a lot of principles involved
in the company but because of the kind
of company they are one of the things
that they do is they send out a field
they send out technicians to the field
and they rotate those techniques
through their different customers and
with and they do inspections of the
devices at the customer site
periodically and they just rotate them
through every quarter they'll go through
a different set of customers one of
those groups one of the one of the
people in one of those groups noticed
that there were small cracks in a few of
the brackets that attach that device to
the truck wheel small cracks none of the
customers have noticed the cracks at all
that customer didn't notice them but the
field technician immediately gets in
touch with the CEO asks lets him know of
what the problem what the problem is
brings that device brings back the ones
that have cracked brings it back to the
lab and the company immediately goes
into a diagnostic situation and we are
the engineers because one of the
principles of this company is to
celebrate when things are broken things
break they celebrated as an opportunity
similar to the crisis is a terrible
thing to waste
right whenever something goes wrong this
company really loves it and the
engineers love to try to figure out what
happened and they're able to figure out
that there there is a flaw and they have
they're able to reap they were all
excited they were able to recreate the
problem right I mean just because you
can actually find out and figure out why
this is happening
and 5% or less of the devices will fail
will will actually have a crack
developing them and that will happen
only after about 300,000 miles which is
about how much you travel in about three
years as a truck so that crack can
happen and then if that little crack
happens about a year or two later you
could wind up with the device actually
potentially breaking off the wheel which
would be potentially a very difficult
safety situation so the company and the
students discuss this in debate this and
the company decides is deciding should
it send out a safety bulletin to alert
the customers customers inspect their
their trucks every quarter they may sell
to these truck fleets and and they come
in for maintenance every quarter well
they could send something out to say
when the truck comes in for maintenance
look for little cracks and if a little
crack happens then maybe we do something
about it we could replace it we could we
could have them buy a new one because
the the item is only warrantied for two
hundred thousand for actually for one
hundred thousand miles which is industry
standard but and so this doesn't happen
until three to five years later or they
could say you know what we this is this
is bad we should recall the product we
should recall all the brackets nothi
not the actual total product but just
the brackets and if so should we recall
all of them should we recall them in
stages um and so that's the question
that the company is wrestling with and
in the case in the case there's some
more discussion about all the different
principles involved in the companies but
I want to say I want you to think about
your principles about how you how you
think about the world and as you would
if you were running this company or if
you were a leader in this company what
would you do would you send out a safety
boat so would you send out a safety
bulletin a maintenance bulletin saying
that you should you should inspect this
and wait if you find these things will
either bother replace it or make you buy
a new one or something like that would
you recall a subset of the products over
time would you recall all the products
as soon as possible or would you hope
that no one notices and move on and even
and by the way this is a private company
it's a start-up a lot of pressures on
them
new report to a Board of Directors
problem probably a lot of investors and
venture capital so it's not a public
company grant play out in that way but
it is an intense situation thinking
about those other stakeholders and yes
and and so as you vote on this realize
obviously that we haven't given you all
the information and it's almost unfair
to ask you to vote on what you would do
because I've described to you that you
want to prior you want to make your
decision based on the prioritization of
a series of principles within the
context of this situation and so forth
for those of you that decided that you
would recall the product as soon as
possible I'd like you to think about for
a second but what if I told you that it
was going to cost $750,000 to recall all
the products fifty thousand dollars is
that changed is that it does that make
you more or less likely to want to
that's probably a good bit of cash
that's the next question right does that
change if I tell you that the company
only has a million dollars left in the
bank yeah time right and so you you can
you can understand that you as a company
can have a series of principles in this
company could have different principles
some principles about how you treat a
customer some principles about how you
treat your employees some principles
about how you want to continue to
operate profitably and financially and
you need to prioritize those principles
within in this particular context and so
if if if you were down to your last
dollar of cash you might make a
different decision all right or maybe
not you know in some circumstances you
would under all circumstances recall the
product this tom is actually very
similar to the percentages that I've
gotten as I've taught this course around
the world and Stanford amazingly not so
different anywhere in the world on any
level student at any level of
running people running companies and and
what's intriguing is the company
recalled started to recall they started
a process whereby within a year they had
recalled every single bracket that was
that was in the in the field now prom
they obviously also had to develop and
design a new bracket and and then and
the reason is and this is this is a
particularly its I so I believe that
principals need to be as explicit as
possible
I think principals should should in
order to inform decisions principals
should be more than one or two words
they might he might actually have half a
page written about the principle after
it words to understand what you mean by
it and so for this company one of the
most important principles for them was
the following when it relates to
customers when we set an expectation
with a customer we own it and because
this company had set the expectation
that this bracket was not going to be it
was not going to need inspection that
this bracket was going to last they had
set that expectation with their
customers and so therefore they lived up
to that expectation this was a design
flaw if they had from a start expected
this to need to be inspected and if this
thing was only going to last 300,000
miles they would have come to a
different different decision and they
are I mean this was not a clear decision
this was not an easy decision they
debated it like crazy they debated it
with their board they did all kinds of
things but in the end you know it's one
thing to have a rule that says principle
that says the customer is always right
or the customer is number one or
something like that but when you have a
principle that's that explicit it really
helps inform decisions and before I wrap
up here I just want to I just want to
share with you that generally speaking
what I like about this is it's a
transportation situation
and it's not an obvious situation where
you would have done the recall right we
even had one person in Europe who said
if if that if I were on the board of
directors of this company
and the CEO had chosen to do this recall
I would have fired the CEO all right and
I want to have it or I want to have a
conversation with students where it's
okay for that person to say that in
front of the CEO and that's what we wind
up doing in this class so what are your
takeaways so so so the takeaways tom for
this for this class and and for for the
for the folks that are listening we
believe that you should be explicit
about your values and principles within
the organizations and frankly within
your own life right by doing that you
will manage decisions more efficiently
and more effectively we believe that you
should evolve and prioritize your
principles wisely principles do evolve
over time and when they conflict and
they will conflict prioritize those
within the context of a particular
decision and by doing that you're going
to continue to enhance your principles
and develop a self-reflection that will
that will allow you to grow and make
better and better decisions very
important to communicate effectively
those principles explicitly in order for
your organization to scale in order for
everyone to make better decisions
throughout the organization people
should be aware of what those decisions
are what those principles are so that
person working for Facebook and Myanmar
has a sense of those principles and can
make decisions about whether content
should be online when that content is
killing people and then walk the talk
executes according to your principles if
you have a principle that says if we set
an expectation with a customer we own it
then as the CEO or as a leader in the
company or as a leader in your
organization make sure that you are
living up to those principles and
creating the virtuous cycle that you can
create as anybody within any of these
organization
conducive so that's what I would
encourage you to do and with that I turn
it back to Tom to highlight a few other
resources that you folks can can pursue
and then open it up for questions thanks
Jack and thanks for everything you've
been doing in this regard I hope
everybody on the webinar enjoyed this as
much as I did I've seen this before of
course but every time I learned
something and I hope you did as well
I also this stimulates everybody on the
webinar to learn more and there's a few
URLs on the right-hand side of your
screen from what I understand but one I
already mentioned which was the site
that talks about what we're trying to do
at stvp and our ethics group and we call
that peek
the other two are at other organizations
and and in our you know due diligence
and research to find out what's going on
in the field we came across a couple
that I highly recommend our friends just
down Silicon Valley towards San Jose at
the markula Centre for applied ethics at
Santa Clara University they have a
terrific set of resources or some
combination of resources on ethical
decision-making and on the issues facing
society technology and ethics so like I
urge you to check them out they also
want to bring your attention to another
organization that is a combination of
Institute of the future and the meteor
network of that NGO about something
called ethical OS and that specifically
talks about the digital technology
issues with ethics and it's a set of
frameworks to work through and analyzing
the consequences of new technology so
yet I urge you to have that take a look
at that the last two are collections of
videos at our site that we maintain of
founders and CEOs and venture
capitalists and others that we think are
short form videos they're embedded in
the peek site some of them but if you
wanted to learn more
those links will take you to our site
called Ecore for a lunch Premiership
corner and everything is free all this
is no charge so I urge you to take a
look at that I also just want to quickly
say a couple of words of gratitude to a
number of people jacket I already
mentioned we've been collaborating as
you can see from the peak site
collaborating closely with Laura Dunham
at the University of st. Thomas and
Minneapolis Minnesota she is in charge
of their entrepreneurship education site
but she has her PhD from the universe of
Virginia in these kinds of issues
philosophy ethics of business and
specifically entrepreneurship so it's
been wonderful to work with her as well
as John Feld who is our counterpart at
Duke University in North Carolina and I
was very very lucky to to be a visiting
professor now and will be again drop in
visiting professor at Duke in the
University of North Carolina that helped
support me as we started all this effort
in 2018 and will continue to work on in
2020 and 2001 so I'm very appreciative
to Duke into University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill so with that in
mind we'd like to do some Q&A for the
remaining time yeah you know thank you
guys so much for joining us today I mean
it's a wonderful presentation and to be
honest you know these questions I I
anticipate to be fairly simple and when
Jack added a little bit more context I
could see how it gets a little a little
gray so to speak so we'll go ahead and
jump into the Q&A with Jack and Tom and
we had a lot of great questions and
unfortunately don't know that we'll be
able to get through all them but what I
would like to do is share them with Tom
and Jack after this webinar so that we
can go ahead and hopefully get you guys
some responses so I'm starting off with
one that really kind of stood out and I
think would be interesting for for the
audience here so how do you respond when
when your competitors are not following
the rules they might cheat and lie and
in order to win more clients can the
fact that you are ethical and abide by
the rules actually be a losing position
and I think that that's
that's where you you wind up with a lack
of congruence between your own
organization's values and principles and
those of the community if the community
is your industry for example you could
have an industry where for example in an
online gaming in social media gaming in
mobile gaming there's a set of values
and principles that in order to win you
really need to to to to try to get as
much many dollars out of your customers
as possible and trick them into spending
a lot of money with you mobile gaming is
all about in-app purchases the if you
want to win in that environment it may
be that it may be that you can figure
out a way to do that or it may be that
you just should think about whether
that's an industry that you want to be
working in so that's one side of it the
other is that if the most important
thing though is to be aware and if you
are aware that there is a set of
principles that are and values that are
going on in industry once you're aware
of that you can then at least decide
whether your being having a different
set of values and principles can
actually be a competitive can be a
competitive advantage is there a way of
marketing that is there a way of being
the person who is saying the truth to
their customers that that's actually
going to make a difference if there's
not find another industry I really
believe that if there is then I think
more power to you a couple of examples
in the medical in the medical technology
industry there is an enormous advantage
if you actually are known as doing what
you say you're going to do one of our
protagonists talks it talks in the case
about the the say do the Duke the deuce
the juice a ratio right and it wants to
be as close to one as possible right the
that you do as much of what you say is
possible and and in most industries that
is what that is rewarded in almost all
industries that is rewarded and so over
time you would imagine that by living
your life that way you'll wind up with
better outcome I urge people to Google
the
story and contrasting stories and
outcomes of gusto GU sto a payroll
benefits software company startup that's
now a unicorn and doing great run by a
fellow named Josh Reeves Josh Reeves and
we have videos lots of videos up on him
talking about that situation they found
themselves when they were getting
underway where the competitor was
something called organization called
zenefits which ended up being in a lot
of hot water Allah uber and others at
that time and Josh saw principled
entrepreneurship as a strategic
advantage he it wasn't a constraint like
you know been the rules almost break
them which was sort of the attitude of
the time and but but especially running
a payroll company you know which is it's
a little bit like a medical device and
you do nothing to it correctly
he sees that opportunity because if it
came from his own view in fact some
people said he's the values CEO he made
it such a point when he would everytime
yield but he communicated to his all the
stakeholders that they were going to go
a different way and it paid off so
that's the living case of gusto and
zenefits just Google many of that and
you'll see thank you that was extremely
helpful on and I'm sure the audience
appreciates some examples of companies
where it actually would be tremendously
you know valuable to be ugly and make
that year you know your stance and what
are some of the patterns that you see
around the kinds of organizations or
individuals that fail to prioritize that
face I mean obviously there are a number
of coming that you had mentioned in hot
water in the news that what are some of
the patterns that you see why what leads
them down this road I'll start and maybe
you can do some specific so so so
patters we see and then when we looked
at the curriculum and entrepreneurship
education that we have been using and
many others I might have told you about
this explosion now that's
at every University and any size here's
here's what's going on what was
emphasized was okay come up with an idea
get comfortable that there's an
opportunity and then look for something
called product market fit I mean just go
see what you can find that we'll see is
top priority also along the way start
thinking about how you're going to make
money but more importantly how are you
going to get the message was how you
going to get a large valuation you know
that that that became the badge of honor
that became the metric that seems very
very important all the stuff we've been
talking about was seen as not as not
worthy of their time but frankly given
how much time was being put into these
other endeavors you know to get an
enterprise up and running that values
and that principles got put in the back
seat but I put down and way down the
priority list and and we all know that
when trying to start something new there
isn't time is of the essence in it and
it's very precious and so that's just
tends to get ignored I mean it was and
so they weren't any a lot of attention
being paid the same attention being paid
to trying to get the right product which
is the right market for the same
attention trying to raise money or find
an economic model a business model that
would lead to profitability sometimes
those are important but this latter that
pattern is what we've seen rarely except
for Sage some cases like I mentioned
look and it's just very briefly the one
of the patterns of behavior at at the
company that we discussed that did the
truck tire inflation recall the person
in the field who found the cracks
immediately notified the CEO the CEO
immediately empowered that person to
work with the engineers to try to figure
out what the problem was and then they
went and addressed the situation the
values and principles were those values
and principles were strong and drove
that company
to address the problem whether or not
they decided to do the recall the
communication was there the information
was there they gathered the information
trying to figure it out
contrast that with other situations even
in transportation that we've seen where
when someone finds out about a problem
people scatter people try not to
communicate that effectively they try to
they try to either maybe fix it on their
own or hide it but the the idea that the
communication could be so clear and so
broad is a demonstration of the health
of those values and principles now the
other firm has values and principles
that but that firm's values and
principles might be too you know don't
don't don't share bad news right and
that that's a value that's a principle
that's not necessarily a principle you
might want to have at your company and
if you have that principle whether you
realize it or not if you have that
principle you might you might wind up
with some problems thank you
I think we have time for one quick one
when you have figured out and prior and
prior to prioritize four principles how
do you get them to be adopted
company-wide
like once you figured out great how do
you traction on them well it can help
them when we do this with companies it
can help if you include a reasonable
number of the people at your company in
developing the values and principles
right if you don't just have one person
or even just the leadership team
developing them
so broadly develop those principles and
values and then write them down
explicitly explain them explicitly in a
written document and then set up
sessions where those are those are
communicated widely and then and then
back to back to the previous point and
then walk the talk then make sure that
when the CEO is called by that field
technician and says there's a problem
that the CEO doesn't say well try to fix
it and don't you know and and and don't
tell me about it make sure you're
walking the talk yeah and make the case
that is going to lead to long-term value
creation I mean that this this is will
lead to strategic advantage and will
lead to greater success
look we're not naive it's going to take
the founders the executive team before
to get in alignment and see it's in cita
philosophy but we believe that's the
companies of the 20s and the other
enterprises whether you're doing it for
nonprofit or elsewhere those are ones
are going to make a difference where
this is seen is just as big a risk as
whether the technology will work or not
whether there's a big enough market
that's growing or not whether there is
enough capital to get to profitability
or get to sustainability it's seen as
just as big a risk as that all those
other things thank you guys so much this
was a really great talk
waiting span appreciate how you're
sharing your time with us and if you
join us today thank you so much we will
go ahead and you know connect with Tom
and Jack opera that hopefully gets you
some responses to the remaining
questions and have a great rest of your
day holidays everybody
you